[Music]
after weeks of war these a-race sirens
in kiev have become almost routine
the ukrainian government had seen its
powerful neighbor russia as an
existential threat since the annexation
of crimea in 2014
and it prepared for war and to maintain
order during the conflict
we had a lot of special training the
goal of the training was the
coordination of all law enforcement
units with the armed force to go through
different scenarios
despite kiev's preparation the size and
scale of the invasion was beyond what it
expected russian forces came from the
north east and south of the country
creating a front line stretching more
than two thousand kilometers
and groups of saboteurs allied to russia
were allegedly operating in ukrainian
cities
just in kiev during the first two weeks
of full-scale aggression we discovered
more than 600 sabotage groups their task
was to reach downtown and to block law
enforcement agencies
the state was mostly able to maintain
communication within key cities
american business magnate elon musk
supplied ukraine with about four
thousand starling terminals similar to
tv dishes
they provide the secure satellite
internet access and enable the state to
keep up its surveillance within ukraine
but civilians played the most crucial
role in counter-intelligence
daily we received hundreds on phone
calls from ordinary citizens we were
informed of the behavior of certain
groups who were moving toward the police
department taking pictures of the state
institution drawing shames and putting
marks on important buildings in kiev to
be destroyed
including the buildings in which we are
right now
ukrainian officials say russia planned
to enter kiev in the first 72 hours of
the invasion and circle the downtown
area and capture important members of
the cabinet the house of national police
intelligence service security council
and top army generals they say then
russian forces wanted to take full
control of the ministry of defense
internal affairs and energy to force the
head of state to surrender
despite advice from ukraine's western
allies and his own senior team president
vladimir zelenki stayed in the capital
that's now widely considered to have
been a crucial decision that kept
ukraine's state structure intact cabinet
meetings moved into a network of tunnels
underground
we were forced to go down to bankers we
had many working meetings with bunkers
that was a regular practice including
meetings with the president
russia deployed to mubarak weapons in
ukraine as they are considered highly
effective against defenses like bunkers
i asked minister what measures were
taken to protect the president from them
for understandable reasons i cannot tell
everything
under martial law the state came under
military control with president zelinski
now commander-in-chief at the heart of
all operations
he communicates every day with the
people of ukraine through social media
videos to maintain morale and stability
despite the threat to his life being
ever present
al jazeera kiev